saint-cyr-en-val 3400 habitants plus de
80 hectares d'espacés verts 15000 bulbes
plantés chaque année et une
reconnaissance affiché à l'entrée de la
commune iv fleurs pour démontrer la
volonté politique d'une ville qui soigne
son attractivité à proximité d'une
grande ville comme orléans
il faut avoir un cadre qui fait que les
nuisances qu'ils peuvent être induites
par l'activité sur le parc d'activité
par exemple soient les plus douce
possible et l'embellissement le végétal
fait que tout ceci est est agréable les
24e assises régionales du cadre de vie
et de l'embellissement des communes ne
sont donc pas organisé par hasard à
saint cyr en val
les représentants de l'association
régional du fleurissement ceux qui
attribuent grâce à leur jury une deux ou
trois fleurs aux communes
il développe un argument massue investir
dans le végétal à un coût modéré et un
effet majeur y compris la masse
salariale c'est le coût d'un paquet de
cigarettes par an et par habitant on va
dire 6 à 8 euros
moi je ne fume pas donc je suis pas trop
combien j'aime c'est cet ordre là donc
vous voyez que c'est epsilon epsilon
pour la commune et tout ce que l'on
apporte en matière de santé publique
parce que les espaces verts c'est aussi
un vecteur de santé publique
plusieurs études insiste également sur
les effets sociologique du fleurissement
en ville il fait baisser la tension dans
les quartiers et réintroduit du lien
entre les habitants